brendan schaub harassed for not wearing
a mask on a bike trail
oh dude you would have been so upset
today
why papa's because you realize you were
doing a show with a literal wreath
which one of them i was talking to both
it's like that spider-man meme just
pointing at the other spider-man
on the trail like he always is yeah i'm
turf right back in my home turf drove to
san diego yesterday
that's my home turf going and i'm i mean
i'm
i'm 20 miles out from my house so it's i
mean it's
rattlesnake territory yeah and i'm i
might i listen to
music while i ride my bike and i see a
couple
on horses wow couple and horses wow
what was wow about that i don't know
people ride horses sometimes dude he
said like he saw two people riding
unicorns
yes like yo b i saw like two super
mutants from fallout
and they were riding uh unicorns that
would get a wow
really where is that at that's wild
some deep dirt brick flies says his
pants look like i'm
like i'm suffocating and i can't breathe
a little people just start saying
dumb [ __ ] in the chat because brendan's
on screen
pecker 29 says snakes are bendy
this is like you see brendan on screen
and you're inspired to say the stupidest
[ __ ] that comes to your brain
snakes are bendy
see we're ending on a high note this is
great the world's gonna end at least we
can make fun of this [ __ ] idiot capri
pants
right i mean there's that you're not
gonna take that from me
when i when i'm in the fema camps i can
have the memories
of mocking this overtanned idiot
which one that's a good point
as well these overhanded
right big horses yeah and i was like i
caught my attention
and i can see she's going like this at
me yelling
yeah and i'm like oh maybe they need
he's lying
they're going he's making up a story
this is a lie they're moving through a
lot of booze like
this yeah it's always a different it's
like they're moving through it's not
just like the same bottles
yeah they're going through different
ones he's lying by the way of course he
is
everything he says is a lie he'd help or
maybe they're maybe there's a giant
rattlesnake i think so you mean to tell
me royce that the guy who said that
ufc's leading doctor
oh he talked her right this ha ha hero
is a liar you mean to tell me that guy
would lie yes
or maybe there maybe there's a giant
rattlesnake up thing so i go
excuse me and this lady goes where the
[ __ ] is your mask
where the [ __ ] is your [ __ ] mouth she
didn't say that there's no way that
happened yeah there's no way
nobody believes you brendan you're too
being good at shape for somebody to say
some [ __ ] like that to you
they'll try that [ __ ] on like you know
they pick and choose who they say
probably probably about our
about my age i almost said our age
[Laughter]
okay you know what i'm sorry i hate to
admit this
when i have to begrudgingly admit
something but that was actually that was
funny
that was actually kind of funny god damn
it i had to admit that
i don't like this don't mind sorry
my they're both about my age maybe a
little younger
she goes where the [ __ ] your mouth
where the [ __ ] is your mouth i go
excuse me she goes where the [ __ ] is
your mask
you're risking everybody out here i go
who's out here who's out here she goes
where's your mask i go
why in the world and i'm trying not to
cast that's
the situation i go why in the world
would i wear a mask out here
are you after your goddamn mind yelling
at me but you did curse
she was well where's your [ __ ]
matthew who are you talking to she's
saying where's your [ __ ] she's doing
[ __ ] math
he here's what happened i love that
brian's always
challenging his stories how many times
did she say you're right she just kept
saying it over and over what she look
like
here's what happened he was riding his
bicycle
huffy with the little tassels in the
belt he remember those puffy he was
riding his bicycle
and he's he's he's thinking like bro you
know what would be a really good story
for the show bee
what if i like somebody i'd say like
somebody with horses like
i gotta make it realistic like i can't
just say they were walking
because like that that doesn't sound
like so like what if there were like
motorcycles now that's too dangerous so
like on horses right
and what if like they came up to me and
this is a this is how it you know when a
child makes up a story
i think he was really biking i believe
i'd go a step further
i think he saw some people on horses
that's an area where they would have
that
i think that he was riding without a
mask and i think some people on horses
that probably had masks on
i think a woman shot him for maybe half
a second a dirty look
and he knew in his mind and he made up a
whole fight he's not mad at me for not
wearing a mask or whatever
and then in his mind he filled in all
that and then she was like she was all
like take the [ __ ] mask on
and i was like what [ __ ] and then we
were all like he just kind of felt like
i'm telling you that's what happened
he got a dirty look from some woman and
he was like in his brain it was why the
where the [ __ ] is your mask and then
and then i'm like you should you go how
would i [ __ ] hold on well hold on
hey brian calm down
he is a [ __ ] like considering the
brendan's the [ __ ] ufc fighter
brian's a [ __ ] hot head oh yeah he's
he's what if i beat the [ __ ] out of your
boyfriend so far in this made up story
the boyfriend hasn't said anything he's
he is
he's notorious for being that way and i
have a feeling that that
may have um brave bigot said he's a
sober alcoholic
he's a [ __ ] dry drunk but he's uh
he's definitely probably lost some get
he i have a feeling brian
would have had a better career but i i
think that he has a reputation
for being a hothead if i had to guess
well hold on and their boyfriend goes
yeah dude it's not cool and i'm like
what'd you say he was not
he added oh ah
he added that because brian just said
why don't you tell his boy
why don't you say something to his
boyfriend he just ad-libbed it right now
you saw him just add that to his story
like no no but his boyfriend did say
something
and i was like i'll [ __ ] you up bro so
he is making this story up as he goes
along brian's looking at him like he's
looking at a guy who's making the story
up as he goes along
he'll get this freeze frame and their
boyfriend goes yeah dude it's not cool
and i'm like
what'd you say he was not cool i go
what's not cool
and now they don't have mask on they
have bandanas on
and i go oh you so he ran into butch
cassidy and the sundance kid
[ __ ] jesse james and his crew were
out there [ __ ] okay corral
you [ __ ] dum dums think the bandanas
help you
you think about dancehall and as i say
this the lord upstairs go let's do a
breeze so we can see how stupid they are
breeze comes the things blow up i go oh
wow i can see your entire face
i can see your entire face you think
that's helping i see you know what you
guys should do
you should wait because there's i pass a
few uh uh bike lists on the way
none of them are wearing masks because
we're not morons so when they come you
guys should ruin your whole day
and wait here like it's your job because
nobody's paying you the taxpayers aren't
paying to do this
you guys should wait here and then yell
at the other guys coming
and as there's tell me some uh the two
guys who has passed them
i was talking when we get to the top
they come by and she goes
where's your mask and they just start
laughing and keep running by i said i
should have done that
but i i thought you were i thought you
were worn by a snake and i said
that but you just said all of this
i love how he can't by the way when you
tell a story like this
he did call him bikeless by the way
robert gaving in this chat did he call
him bike list
he said a bicyclist
he's no but he's a breathing because a
briefs are sweeping the niche
um bike list he
this is how you can tell when somebody's
telling a [ __ ] story
because he's he can't even remember what
was said he's like and then i was all
like you know because the people aren't
paying the tax the taxpayers aren't
paying you so it's not your job
but you should go pretend like it's your
job and go down there like it's because
it's not your job though and and then i
would ah and i was was like
you don't remember that like where am i
good example years ago my buddy john in
north carolina got into a fight
with some [ __ ] tourists in carolina
beach
because he was parking in his parking
space in our apartment complex
and he kind of jerked in front of them
because they were going to try to take
his spot because everybody steals spaces
in the summertime
so he jerked into that spot and was
getting out after work and you could
hear some [ __ ] redneck guy that
redneck guy was like
man let's see this is why i [ __ ] hate
all these yankees because these [ __ ]
yankees come down here and blah blah and
john was like
the [ __ ] you just say to me i [ __ ]
live here [ __ ] why don't you take
your [ __ ] ass back to wallace or
wherever the [ __ ] you came from and the
guy was like
he just left or whatever you know john
relayed that story to me later
he had no problem recalling every word
verbatim of what was said because he was
you know you get fired up and then
you're like you know what this [ __ ]
said to me today
and i told him you don't [ __ ] like he's
just like and then i was like uh what
did i say
what did i say um that you because
you're not you just
it's not your job why don't you keep
he's a [ __ ] mess trenton wade says
brendan sounds like a kid stalling for
bedtime
that's what he's doing still your
bedtime brady you got to go to bed no
i'm going to tell you a story about
school the other day
go to bed complete waste my time and
then
the boyfriend says something goes yeah
well we're on here tomorrow you better
wear a mask i was like
holy [ __ ] i went you're serious dude he
said you better wear a mask and then i
like punched a horse and i knocked him
out like it was blazing saddles
there you go dude i'm on this trail
every day i'll be back here
tomorrow at 9 00 a.m i might write
[ __ ] naked just to prove a point
uh you know what it is i mean brennan
please don't i hope he's telling the
truth i hope
we're wrong and this was a real story
and i hope he goes bicycling tomorrow
and i hope he's bike listening
bike listening tomorrow thank you and i
hope he gets
knocked the [ __ ] out by some fruit
picking five foot five men
that's what i hope i want to see on tmz
brandon shaub gets knocked out at a park
by some civilian
that would make me laugh hysterically
and he would have no street cred
he gets trampled by a horse that would
be [ __ ] funny too
the horse just kicks him off of his
huffy and this just
in the horse has been signed to ufc for
two years finding jon jones
i go yeah and how about
well where's the math for your horses
you know
oh you don't care about animals oh my
god you know you know your horse can get
it
you can't your horse can't get covered
19. when is the horse ever been infected
i don't know what divorces got in corota
virus you know what i hate to ask this
question because i know it's just going
to frustrate you but royce is here
yes okay why are you asking that of
course
is this man she was knight [ __ ] yeah
that's the stupidest thing
you didn't know horses can get it and
they can have you looked it up horses
can get it
bring that up to they go there it's
called equine coronavirus and it's been
around since 2017.
it is a different kind of coronavirus
they just say brave pick it in the chat
riots in the street can horses get it
that's what you're typing into google
right now
can horses get a coronavirus
i know
justin
you don't know horse can get like oh oh
and i go bubba
you guys watch cnn you've been watching
cm you're scared straight this is the
first time leaving the house
this first time leaving the house you
guys have no idea no way you wear masks
except for you [ __ ]
so you you're still fighting with these
people on horses
yeah none of this happened by the way no
i know but in his make-believe but i'm
saying even in a [ __ ] made-up story
you're stretching it out too these kind
of things don't if if
if a loud disagreement goes that long
it'll come to blows by that point you're
not just going to keep yelling
like this is silver tip this is how i
would have done it right let's say i'm
riding a black royce you
you'll be a lady and go you know hey
where's your mask
so i'm riding past
are you not gonna do the thing
am i the guy on the bike no i'm the guy
on the bike um okay i'm the guy on the
horse
hey why aren't you wearing your mask you
stupid shut up
that's the end of it keep pedaling it's
that simple i've done this many times in
my life
how many times in your life have you
been out about somebody tries to shame
me for something
it goes shut up just go on about your
day
done that a thousand times in my life
shut the [ __ ] up
and you just and when they go no but
you're not you just keep walking away
you don't keep going